ah
[Música]
si ya se convirtió en el cuarto país en
américa latina en confirmar la
existencia de la variante delta en su
territorio después de argentina méxico y
perú el ministro de salud enrique parís
confirmó la llegada de esta variante en
una paciente de 43 años chilena pero
residente en eeuu las autoridades
informaron que se realizó pcr a todo el
avión que viajaba con ella y por el
momento resultó negativo la llegada de
la variante delta preocupa en el país en
un momento que se produce un descenso
sostenido en el número de casos en el
que avanza la vacunación un 80 por
ciento de la población chilena y ha
recibido una primera dosis y más de 65
por ciento de la población chilena
objetivo ha recibido las 2
completado así su vacunación la llegada
de la variante delta supuso la caída en
bolsa de la empresa y la tam airlines
que se verá afectada por las
restricciones a los viajes y el cierre
de fronteras que se mantendrán en el
país hasta al menos el próximo 14 efe
[Música]
aunque los casos de kobe de en eeuu
siguen disminuyendo 1 de cada 5 casos
reportados son de la variable delta es
decir el 20,6 por ciento de los casos
hoy corresponden a esta variable una
cifra muy superior teniendo en cuenta
que en abril de este año la variable
delta solo era responsable del 0,1 por
ciento de los casos según anthony fauci
pidió homólogo de la casa blanca la
variada libertad es ahora la amenaza más
grande en eeuu para acabar con la
pandemia sin embargo agrega que las
vacunas autorizadas logran contenerla
de hecho la vacuna de facer tiene un 88
por ciento de efectividad contra delta y
lo que dice el centro de control y
prevención de enfermedades es que el
riesgo más alto está para las personas
que no se han vacunado el reto más alto
sin embargo para eeuu es lograr que más
personas se vacunen y evitar así la
propagación de esta variable y de otras
más
[Música]
entre sí las autoridades han culpado de
los nuevos casos de coronavirus en moscú
y en otras ciudades al nihilismo de la
población también a las bajas tasas de
vacunación y a las mutaciones la temible
variante delta el país confirmó el
viernes 20.000 nuevos casos de
coronavirus el número más alto desde
enero el 90% de estos nuevos casos según
algunos medios se deben a la variante
india de alta la ciudad de moscú ha
detectado más de 9.000 infecciones en un
solo día por coronavirus un máximo en
todo el tiempo de pandemia y ante esta
tercera ola el alcalde moscovita insiste
en hacer la vacunación obligatoria para
camareros taxistas conductores y hasta
un 60% de las personas que trabajan de
cara al público además a partir del
lunes los cafés y restaurantes de moscú
sólo permitirán la entrada a los que
puedan presentar un código qr que
demuestre que han sido vacunados contra
el coronavirus o que han pasado la
enfermedad o tienen una pcr negativa